[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
SARAH HEWETT: All
right, good afternoon.
We should get
started, because we
have a lot to talk about today.
So today is the second in
a series of three lectures
about the essential oil lab.
You'll get a third
lecture and a little bit
about X-ray crystallography.
But today, we're going
to finish talking
about the main synthetic
parts that you'll be
doing in the essential oil lab.
So today, we're going
to talk about how
if your separation worked.
And before I get
too far into that,
there was a question
in the Tuesday lecture
about the naming of terpenes.
And so if you
remember, the terpenes
come from the
isoprene structure,
which was five carbons
and eight hydrogens.
But then there are some
terpene derivatives,
like menthol, that
don't necessarily
have that five carbon,
eight hydrogen structure.
So this obviously has an O-H
group and more hydrogens.
And so what I found
in the literature
is that there are
terpenes, which
follow the strict pattern.
And then there are
terpenoids, which
are derivatives of terpenes.
They are synthesized
from the same backbone.
But then they get extra
hydrogenation or oxidation
done to them.
So, like, your carvone has
the oxygen double bond in it.
So that's technically
a terpenoid.
They seem to be referred
to pretty interchangeably
in the literature, which
I thought was interesting.
But that is probably
the more accurate way
to name these
types of compounds.
So hopefully, that clears up a
little bit of that confusion.
So jumping in to the rest of the
essential oil lab, on Tuesday,
we talked about
what you're going
to do on day one
of the lab, which
is you'll get your essential
oil, which will either
be spearmint oil or caraway
oil, and you will separate it
into its two major components,
which are your carvone, there
on the left, and your limonene.
So essentially, you'll take
an oil that looks like that,
and you'll separate it into
two other oils that will also
look really similar
to that first one,
except hopefully,
they're pure compounds.
So if you do your vacuum
distillation really well,
and you separate those, and
you get two pure compounds,
we need to figure out how to
characterize your separation,
and figure out how well you were
able to separate your carvone
from your limonene.
And we're going to do that
in a whole number of ways.
You'll get a lot of experience
with different analytical
techniques.
And these are the major
methods that we're
going to be using
to characterize
the success of your separation.
So we'll be doing refractometry,
gas chromatography,
infrared spectroscopy,
polarimetry,
and X-ray crystallography.
And so today,
we're going to talk
about the first four of those.
And then, like I said,
in a week or two,
Peter Muller from the
X-ray crystallography lab
will come and do a much more
detailed explanation of X-ray
crystallography and
what information you
can get from that.
So to start with,
refractometry--
refractometry is a way to
measure the refractive index
of a compound.
And that is a
characteristic property
of different compounds.
And it is-- it comes from the
ratio of the velocity of light
and air to the velocity
of light in a liquid.
So you have your light
traveling through the air.
Then it hits the liquid
and it slows down,
and it changes the angle.
So you'll notice, if you
ever look through some water,
you'll know that the image
is slightly distorted.
And that is because of water
having a different refractive
index, or water having--
the light slows down as it
travels through the water.
So all of our organic
liquids-- so like I said,
you're going to be separating
your oil into two other oils.
So we'll have liquids, which
means that they will have
refractive indices as well.
And most organic liquids
will have a refractive index
somewhere from 1.3 to 1.7.
And the way that you calculate
that is it's represented as n.
And you can either do
the ratio of the velocity
of the light in the
air to the velocity
of the light in the liquid.
But that is hard to measure.
So in the lab, we can
measure the angles
at which the light travels.
So if you have light that
is coming through the air--
so if this part is the air,
and you have your light,
it'll hit your liquid
interface at a certain angle,
which is theta from
straight up and down.
And then, it'll get refracted
at a different angle.
We call that theta prime.
So you can measure
that in the lab
and calculate your
refractive index.
The refractive index is
dependent on the wavelength
of light.
So you might imagine that
if the refractive index
and how much this angle--
and how much the speed
of the light changes
is dependent on how the light
interacts with your liquid,
then it'll depend on the
properties of your light-- so
the wavelength-- and the
properties of your liquid.
And one that we care
about is the density.
So the way that we
account for this
is that we have the
refractive index.
And we call it
refractive index D20.
And so D represents that you use
light from the sodium D line.
So if you remember from,
maybe, gen chem or physics,
if you heat up an element
very hot so it emits light,
you can--
each element has a
characteristic set
of wavelengths of
light that it emits.
And sodium's happens
to be around--
its brightest emission happens
to be around 586 nanometers.
So if you use a sodium lamp,
and you can select for these 586
nanometers, then you get a
characteristic one wavelength
of light that you can
pass through your sample.
So you know what
the wavelength is,
and you can know that
you're just getting
that one wavelength of light.
And then, you want to make
sure that all of your samples--
or your measurements are taken
at 20 degrees Celsius so that
the density of your liquid.
So if you change
the temperature,
you change the density.
So we'd make all
of our measurements
at 20 degrees Celsius.
And here are the approximate
refractive indices
of limonene and carvone.
And you can find
different values for them
in the literature, because
the compounds that they
used to measure these
in the literature
are of different purities.
So you can by limonene and
carvone at 95%, or 96%,
98% purity.
And depending on
what purity you use,
you'll get a slightly
different value.
But they should be
within that range.
And when we measure
them in the lab,
we go out to four
decimal places.
The way that we'll
do this in the lab
is with the refractometer.
And this is a picture of the
refractometer in the lab.
And this part over here is
the prism or the crystal.
And so you'll put
your liquid sample--
you just put a few drops
right on the crystal.
And then, you close the lid and
the refractometer instrument
shines light
through your sample.
It can measure-- it knows
what angle the light is
hitting the sample at.
And then it can measure how
much light it gets back out.
So it'll change the angle
of the incident light
until it gets total internal
reflectance until it
reaches the critical angle.
You remember from physics?
And so once it figures out
what the critical angle is,
then it can figure out
the refractive index
of your sample.
And so it'll tell you what the
refractive index is right here.
You don't even really
have to do any math.
And it'll also tell you
what the temperature is.
So you want to make sure that
it's stabilized at 20 degrees
before you actually
take your measurement.
And that's about it.
So it's a pretty easy
measurement to take,
but it will help you to identify
the purity of your compounds,
because the
refractive index is--
we can think of it as a
linear quantity made up
of the refractive indices
of the two substances
that we have in our mixture,
multiplied by their molar
fraction.
So your refractive
index of a mixture
is the sum of the
refractive index
of pure limonene times your
mole fraction of your limonene,
plus your refractive index of
your carvone times your molar
fraction of your carvone.
And so that you don't have to
sell for a million variables,
if you remember
the mole fraction,
mole fractions have
to add up to 1.
So your mole
fraction of limonene
is 1 minus your mole
fraction of carvone.
So you can plug that in up there
and, using the measurements
that you take in
the lab, you can
solve for the mole
fractions of each
of these components in
both of your fractions
that you collect from
your distillation.
And you can determine
their purity that way.
So another way to determine the
purity of your-- or fractions
that you've collected is
through gas chromatography.
And this is a picture of the
GC instrument in the lab.
And it's right next to the
ICPMS, so you may have seen it
if you were in lab yesterday.
And if not, you can take
a peek and see it today.
So this is the
instrument itself.
This is the autosampler.
So you guys will make
your sample vials,
put them in up here, and then
it'll pick them up, put them
into the instrument, and
then it'll automatically
inject the sample for you,
which is kind of nice.
And then this
thing over here, it
generates hydrogen
and air, which
are used in the detector
of the instrument.
So the way that
gas chromatography
works, if you wanted to take
a peek inside the instrument
in a very, very
simplified fashion,
you have a carrier gas,
which in our case is helium.
And the carrier gas,
if you think about-- so
this is a type of
chromatography.
And you guys did chromatography
in the ferrocene lab
with your thin layer
chromatography and your column
chromatography.
So in your TLC and in your
column chromatography,
what was your stationary phase?
AUDIENCE: Alumina?
SARAH HEWETT: Alumina, yes.
So you had your alumina, and
it was coated on the TLC plate.
Or you packed your
column with the alumina,
and that's your
stationery phase.
And then, what was
your mobile phase?
AUDIENCE: Hexanes
and ethyl acetate?
SARAH HEWETT: Hexanes
and ethyl acetate.
And you guys made
different mixtures of those
to determine the best
separation of your compound.
So in thin layer chromatography
and in column chromatography,
which of those phases had
a bigger determination
on the separation of
your two components?
AUDIENCE: The mobile phase?
SARAH HEWETT: The
mobile phase, yeah.
So you could change
the polarity and it
would change the separation.
In gas chromatography,
it's kind of the opposite.
So you have your carry your gas.
And that's going to
be your mobile phase.
So that'll help push your
compounds through the column.
And then the column is
your stationary phase.
And you can change
the properties
of your stationary phase
in order to separate--
get different types
of separation.
So there are two major
types of compounds that they
use in column chromatography.
And the first one, this is--
anyone know what this is?
Polyethylene glycol,
which is something
you may have heard of before.
So these are your ethyl
groups, and then the glycol,
because it's got alcohol groups.
And so this notation is
the notation for a polymer.
So the way that
this is written is
you could have any number
of this repeating unit
until the end.
And this is a polar
stationary phase.
So if you're trying to
separate compounds that
have differences-- large
differences in polarity,
a lot of times you'll
use the polar compound.
Because it has these oxygens
that have their lone pairs.
So it can interact
with polar compounds,
it can form hydrogen bonds,
all kinds of neat stuff.
But the one that we're
going to use in the lab
is this compound here.
And it is called a polysiloxane.
So polysiloxane-- and it has
these silicon groups that
have to methyl groups attached.
And another name for this
particular-- so polysiloxane
is the overarching name for
this class of compounds.
This one has two
methyl groups attached.
So one of the other names
for it is dimethicone.
I don't know if you've
heard of that before.
It's in a lot of things.
They use it extensively
in lotions, shampoos,
and sometimes in food.
It prevents foaming and it makes
things feel nice and slippery.
So that's why they use it in a
lot of cosmetics, and lotions,
and everything.
So the next time
you're in the bathroom,
you can take a look at
some of your products.
And you may see dimethicone.
And now you know
what it looks like.
And we're going to
use it in the lab
to help separate your
limonene and your carvone
to see how pure
your separation was.
And the GC column
looks like this.
So it's represented in this
diagram as a curled up circle.
And so this is actually
what it looks like.
So this is an old column taken
out of the GC in the lab.
And you can see that
it's very, very thin.
So this is a capillary column.
So this is actually
a hollow tube.
And your sample will travel
through this tube around,
around, around.
Does anyone have a guess
about how long this is?
AUDIENCE: Long.
SARAH HEWETT: Long.
[LAUGHS] Yeah, so this is 30
meters of capillary tubing
all wrapped up here.
And on the inside of
the capillary tubing,
it is coated with this
polysiloxane mixture which
will interact with your sample.
And it'll help cause
the separation.
So your sample gets inserted
into the injector port.
This is an oven, so
it gets heated up.
And you can change the
difference in the temperature.
And so the difference
in the temperature
will change the amount of
separation that you get.
So if you do it hotter,
then your compounds
will travel through
faster, and you don't maybe
get as good of a separation.
If you cool it
down a little bit,
then you tend to get
better separation,
but sometimes it can
broaden your peaks.
So there's a trade-off there.
We have already made
a program for you
that optimizes the separation
of the two compounds
that you guys are looking for.
So you don't have
to worry about that.
You'll just make up
your sample, inject it,
it'll go through the column, and
then it reaches the detector.
And we use a flame
ionization detector.
So that hydrogen in the
air, they get lit on fire.
The stuff that comes out of
the column goes into the fire.
It gets lit on fire,
it produces ions,
and then the ions are detected
by the detector, changes
the electrical current.
And that is what
gives you your signal.
This is a very
sensitive technique.
So you do not need to prepare
very concentrated amounts
of samples.
So we're not going to
inject your oil straight
into the instrument.
You are going to do what's
called a double dilution.
So you will take 50
microliters of your sample
in one of those micropipettes
that you guys have been using.
You'll dissolve it in 1
milliliter of pentane,
so you're already making
a very dilute solution.
And then you'll take 50
microliters of that solution,
and you will dissolve it in
another milliliter of pentane.
And that's what you will
inject into the GC instrument.
Your TAs will help
you with that.
But that's just to show you that
it is a very, very sensitive
technique.
So you do not need
a lot of volume.
This is what the output
of the GC looks like.
And you will get your
GC chromatograph.
And the units on this are in
abundance and time in minutes.
And so you can see that this is
a GC chromatograph of the oil
before it's been separated.
So it has two major
components and a couple
of smaller impurities.
And hopefully, if you guys do
your distillation correctly,
then you'll get--
your fractions will
look like there's not
very much of one and
a lot of the other,
and then vice versa for your
limonene and your carvone.
And the way that you can
tell which peak is which
is that-- so this column
is pretty non non-polar,
like I said.
And the interactions
with the column
are what separates your mixture.
But the way that it
is separated is mostly
through boiling point.
So when you heat
this compound up--
and we'll talk about it a little
bit more in the next slide--
but it'll travel
through the column.
So things that are more volatile
will travel through the column
faster, so things with
lower boiling point.
And then, things with
a higher boiling point
stay on the column for longer.
So you can use boiling
point to sort of identify
your compounds.
And you also get
this information
at the bottom, which tells
you the retention times
of your peaks in the minutes.
And then, it'll also tell
you the area of your peak.
And you can use the percent
area to calculate your percent
purity.
So in this case, we have 41%
of one and 57% of the other.
So it is not a very pure sample.
And hopefully, yours will get on
the order of-- you can get well
above 90% separation.
So that'll give you
an idea of how well
your distillation went.
So some things about
gas chromatography
that are important to note is
that you can't really identify
an unknown without a standard.
So if you just-- if you don't
know what your compound is
already and you
inject it into the GC,
all you're going to know
is that retention time.
It doesn't give you any
information about its structure
or anything else.
So you can compare
retention times.
Those are consistent
as long as you
use the same method,
and the same column,
and the same carrier gas.
But you need to have a standard
that you can compare it to.
Or if you know that there's
two components in your mixture,
if you know what's in them, then
you can tell which is which,
again, by their boiling point.
So it is very useful
for determining
the purity or the percent
composition of a sample, which
is what we're going
to use it for.
And like I said,
separation is determined
by your stationary phase.
And the stationary phase is
a liquid coating on there.
So when you're using
GC chromatography,
you want to make sure that you
pick a stationary phase that
matches the type of compound
that you're separating.
So we're going to use
this non-polar one
because our compounds
are relatively non-polar.
But you'll see it
used in extensively
in other applications.
So if you're doing a
lot of polar compounds
with a lot of oxygen
groups or nitrogen groups,
then you may want to use
a more polar compound.
You can also get chiral
stationary phases that
will help separate enantiomers.
There's all kinds.
If you go on any of the
Agilent website or anything,
you can get a whole
list of different types
of stationary phases with
different types of polarity.
You can substitute these methyl
groups out for other things
depending on what application
you're trying to use it for.
And so the way that
we can characterize
the efficiency of the separation
is by theoretical plates.
And we mentioned this
really, really briefly when
we were talking about
the distillation.
So if you remember,
there was the grow column
versus the simple distillation.
So you get better
separation when
you have more and more of those
cycles where the vapor can
vaporize and recondense.
Does that sound
vaguely familiar?
Good.
So essentially, that's what's
happening in this GC column.
So you have a liquid coating
on the inside of this tube.
And your compounds are
traveling through it.
And they can be heated
up so they'll repeatedly
dissolve and then
revaporize in the liquid.
And the more times they
can do that as they travel
through this 30 meters of
column, the more efficient
your separation is going to be.
And we can calculate
that using a measure
called theoretical plates.
And it is based on the
idea that one plate
is one equilibrium between
the liquid in the vapor
phase, or one of those
vaporization recondensation
cycles.
So you can refer to the
temperature composition
diagrams from the
last lecture if you
want to get a refresher on
what I mean by the vaporization
and recondensation.
And then, you can calculate this
from your chromatogram data.
So when you have that
chromatograph data
that has the peaks on it,
you can use this equation.
So n is the number of
theoretical plates.
This is just a
standard constant.
And then your tr is
the retention time.
So you'll use the retention
time of your peak in some unit.
And then you want to take
the width of the peak
at 1/2 of the
height of the peak.
So I can't go backwards.
Oh, there it is.
So for this peak, you would say
your retention time is 1.434.
And then, you would want
to go halfway up the peak,
and then take the width of
that peak, which is going
to be a very small number.
And the best way to do this
is to probably use a ruler,
and actually
measure, physically,
the height of the peak,
and then measure the width
at the halfway point.
So if you do that, you
need to make sure that when
you are using
these measurements,
that they are in the same units.
So you can either
do it in the units
of time, which is what it's
given to you on the GC.
But it's probably
a little easier
if you do it in
millimeters or centimeters,
however you want to measure it.
Just make sure that
you also-- if you're
going to measure your width
in centimeters or millimeters
that you also measure your
retention time in centimeters
or millimeters.
And the retention
time is just the time
from the beginning to
where your peak is.
So that's GC spectroscopy.
And now, we can talk a little
bit about IR spectroscopy.
And if we take a
moment and think
about our
electromagnetic spectrum,
we can think about the
different types of energy
that you have available in
the electromagnetic spectrum.
So if this is our
wavelength in meters,
what is our thing with the
smallest wavelength, highest
energy?
Anyone?
Gamma rays.
Then?
AUDIENCE: X-rays?
SARAH HEWETT: Then?
UV.
The little tiny one?
AUDIENCE: Visible.
SARAH HEWETT: Visible.
AUDIENCE: And then infrared.
SARAH HEWETT: Infrared.
AUDIENCE: Microwave.
SARAH HEWETT: And then,
yeah, microwave and radio.
All right, so from highest
energy to lowest energy,
this is our
electromagnetic spectrum.
And so IR spectroscopy
uses IR radiation
to give us information
about a molecule.
And the way that this
happens is that it's
very useful for identifying
functional groups
in a molecule.
And you pass this IR radiation
through the molecule.
And all of the bonds
in your molecule
have some sort of vibrational
energy associated with them.
They're vibrating at
a certain frequency
which corresponds to energy in
the IR region of the spectrum.
So if you pass IR radiation
through your sample,
then some of the
wavelengths will match up
with the frequencies of the
vibrations of your bonds.
And it will get absorbed.
And then, you can measure
how much light comes back out
and how much light
gets absorbed.
And you can get an IR spectrum
of your molecule, which
is representative of all the
different bonds and the energy
that they absorb.
The frequency of light or
energy that a bond absorbs
is dependent on the
mass of the two atoms
that are attached in the
bond, the bond strength,
and the chemical environment.
And this is related
by Hooke's law,
if you're familiar with
physics, that talks about-- you
can think about it as two
masses on opposite ends
of the string-- or a spring.
And so how much force you
need, or what the frequency is
that that spring
will oscillate on
depends on all of these factors.
And so if you have something
that has a high bond
order, like a double bond or
a triple bond, then those--
that's a really tight spring.
So it's going to vibrate
at a very high frequency,
and it's going to take
a lot more energy to get
that vibration to happen.
Whereas if there are
two light atoms that
are attached by a
single bond, then they
will vibrate at a much lower
frequency-- less energy.
Make sense, sort of?
So vibrations are only
IR active if they change
the dipole moment of a bond.
So you can't see all the bonds
in your molecule using IR
spectroscopy.
You'll be able to see the ones--
we can see most of them,
since most molecules are not
perfectly symmetric.
But like carbon-carbon
bonds, that stretch
does not really change
the dipole much.
So you don't see those
very strongly, if at all,
in most of your IR spectra.
So there are a bunch
of different ways
that a bond or a
molecule can vibrate.
And the number of possible
vibrational modes in a molecule
is determined from the
degrees of freedom.
So if you think
about a molecule,
it can move in the
three dimensions
of space translationally.
And so all of the atoms can also
move in the three dimensions
of space.
So you get-- you start
with 3N degrees of freedom,
so N being the number of
atoms in your molecule.
And then in a linear
molecule, you have--
you can also have
rotationally modes.
But one of the
rotationally modes
does not quite work as
well, because it's along
the axis of the bond.
So you're not changing anything
if you rotate it that way.
So we end up with 3N
minus 5 vibrational
stretching or bending modes.
And then, in a
nonlinear molecule,
you get all three translational
and all three rotational modes.
So you do 3N minus 6.
And so that gets rid of the
translational and rotational
motion.
So what's left is
the vibrational
stretching or bending
modes in your molecule.
And so the possible
vibrations that we
can have are as follows--
the symmetric stretch, the
asymmetric stretch, the bend,
the wag, the twist, and rocking.
So I need everybody to stand up.
If you've done this before,
we're doing it again.
This is a rite of passage
in a chemistry lab.
We are going to--
I will wait.
We are going to pretend
that we are molecules,
and we are going to act out all
of these different vibrations
that can happen in your
molecule so that you have
an idea of what you are looking
for when you see your IR
spectrum.
So if your body is like a
carbon, and then the rest of,
like, your legs are
another carbon chain,
then say you have two
hydrogen atoms in your hands.
Great.
We are excellent
methylene groups.
So a symmetric stretch--
any ideas?
Yeah, when they go
at the same time.
Excellent.
The asymmetric stretch?
Yeah, opposite, excellent.
The bend or scissor?
Excellent.
So you're all getting
a workout today.
This is great.
The wag?
The wag is back
and forth, like--
yeah, there you go.
Excellent.
Twisting?
One goes back, one goes forward.
There we go.
And then last one, rocking?
That's what you had before.
They're going back and
forth at the same time.
Excellent!
Well done.
Give yourselves a hand.
It's a good way to get
everybody up and moving.
So those are our IR
vibrational modes,
and those are all the ways that
you can make your molecules
vibrate.
And so now, how do
we measure this?
And this is the
ATR spectrometer.
It's an infrared spectrometer.
This is the one that
we have in the lab.
And it's in the very back
corner by the door in A prime 4.
So some of you guys
may have seen it.
You may have seen some of the
other lab groups coming in
to use it.
And the way that
this works is, it's
a pretty simple instrument
in terms of what
you need to do to use it.
There is a crystal right here.
And the crystals are usually
made of zinc selenide,
or I believe, in our
case, it's a diamond.
And it's a pretty tiny crystal.
It's just that very, very
small little dot in the center.
And you can take your
compound and put it
straight on the crystal.
And if it's a
solid, then you can
use-- this is a
little pressure thing.
So you can lower that, and
it'll press your solid right up
against the crystal so
you get good contact.
Or you can just put a couple
of drops of your liquid right
on the crystal, and then
it has good contact anyway
because it's a liquid.
And-- oh, so the ATR stands for
attenuated total reflectance.
And how it works is you have
a source of your IR energy.
And these are some mirrors.
And so you have your energy.
It comes in here.
It hits the mirror, and
then it gets directed up
through this crystal.
And like I said, you're
going to put your sample
on top of the crystal.
And you want to get really
good contact, because the IR
energy will travel
through the crystal,
and it'll interact with the
very bottom layer of your sample
there.
And then, it'll get
reflected back down.
And in some cases, there's
only one reflection,
and then it goes
to the detector.
And in other cases, depending
on the size of your crystal,
you can get multiple
reflections.
And when the light interacts
with your sample, like I said,
it'll absorb some of the
wavelengths of the IR light.
So some of this
will get absorbed.
And then, that's
the attenuation part
is that some wavelengths
will be decreased
in intensity because they'll
be absorbed by your compound.
And then, the reflectance
part is the light
gets reflected down through
this crystal into the detector.
And then the detector
can determine
which wavelengths of light
were absorbed and how much.
And that is IR in a
very simplified fashion.
There's more descriptions
of it in your Mohrig book.
So if you guys have this book
or if you want to borrow it,
there's an excellent
description of how different
IR spectrometers work.
There are a couple of different
ways to get IR samples.
So like ATR is great
for liquids and solids.
You can also have IR
spectrometers that just--
you set your sample up on
some sort of support that's,
like, vertical.
And then you pass the
beam straight through it,
and you measure what comes
out on the other side,
kind of like the
UV-Vis that you did.
So there's a couple
different ways to do IR.
But this is the way that we're
going to be using in the lab.
And what you get out
of it is an IR spectrum
that looks something like this.
So I took these straight
from the lab manual.
And these are IR
spectra of carvone.
And that's the carvone
from the caraway seed oil,
and that's the carvone
from your peppermint oil.
And do we see any differences?
Not really.
So what do we know is
different about the carvone
from the caraway seed
and the peppermint oil?
The stereochemistry.
So we know that one is the
R form of the molecule,
and the other is the
S. So this is the S
and this is the R.
So is IR spectroscopy
good at differentiating
between isomers?
Nope, not at all.
It just tells you what
functional groups are there.
It doesn't really tell you
in what order they are in.
So you'll need to do a different
spectroscopic technique
if you want to figure that out.
But we can get a
lot of information
about different bonds that
are in our molecule, which
is helpful for identifying
different things.
What do we have next?
So, yeah, we can talk about
interpreting an IR spectrum.
So in your book
or on the internet
there are many, many
charts that have
lists and lists of the IR--
oh, my bookmark fell out.
Oh here it is.
So there is a chart
in the Mohrig book
that has a list of all of
the different stretching
frequencies for different
functional groups.
And it has the
stretching, the bending,
and anything that
you are typically
able to see in an IR spectrum.
And it tells you
where you should
look for it in the spectrum
in terms of wave numbers.
So if you look at the
axes of these things,
the left axis here is
percent transmittance,
so how much of the
light gets through.
And then, the--
so the top is 100.
So if nothing is absorbed,
it'll be a baseline at the top.
And then if things
are absorbed strongly,
then the transmittance goes
down and you get a big peak.
And then the wave, the other
axis along the bottom here,
is--
well, on the bottom of this
one, it's in micrometers.
But in most cases in IR
now, we use wave numbers
because it's a linear
measurement instead
of non-linear.
So wave numbers
corresponds to the amount
of energy in the molecule--
or in the photon.
So we can get these
charts of where
different functional
groups absorb
in terms of wave numbers.
So these are all
in wave numbers,
which is inverse centimeters.
So when you get your
IR spectrum back
and you take it in the lab,
you're going to print it out.
And then, you can use one
of these charts to help you.
And the best place to start
looking at an IR spectrum
is between 4,000 and 1,400 wave
numbers, so, like, this half.
Because you can
see, on this side,
there's a lot
going on down here.
And you might say, oh, that's
got a ton of information in it.
Not so much.
So this is called the
fingerprint region.
And it does have a lot
of information in it.
And before there were other
spectroscopic techniques,
people spent a lot of time
trying to identify peaks down
here.
But they're less representative
of actual specific bonds.
A lot of it's, like, overtones
and other resonance happening.
And these are unique
to every chemical.
So if you have a
reference spectrum
and then you have your
spectrum, you can match them up
and the fingerprint region
should match really well.
But it's kind of
hard to interpret,
and it's usually very messy.
So we kind of ignore
this at the beginning.
And then, if you look
over here, then there's
a lot fewer peaks to
deal with and they
provide a lot of information.
So you'll see that the C-H
stretches are typically around,
like, 2,800 to
3,100 wave numbers.
And it depends on whether
it's a single bond
like an alkane C-H, or
alkene, or an aromatic where
they come out.
So these guys, you'll
have different peaks,
because we have some alkene
C-H's and some alkane C-H's.
So you'll have a whole variety
of C-H stretching there.
And then, what other
functional groups
do we have in the molecule?
What's the other main one?
AUDIENCE: CO.
SARAH HEWETT: The CO.
And the CO double bond is one
of the most characteristic peaks
that you can find
in an IR spectrum.
And it always comes out
somewhere between 1600, 1700.
So you can see, at 1700,
there is this huge peak.
It is the biggest
peak in the spectrum.
And that corresponds to
that CO double bond there.
So that's always a
good place to start
if you are looking to identify
something that you think
may have a carbonyl in it.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So can you tell how
many C-c bonds there are based
on the height of the peak?
SARAH HEWETT: No.
So the height of the
peak doesn't give you
any specific information
like how many there are.
In amines, if you have a primary
versus a secondary amine--
so if you have an
amine with 1 H on it,
and some other R group
versus two H's, you'll
see either two peaks and
the amine or one peak.
So that's when you can
quantify atoms through this.
But no, the intensity
does not always
correspond to how
many of the bond
there are, since the intensity
is mostly a function of how
much the dipole moment changes.
So you could have
a lot of C-H bonds,
but you won't see a whole--
like, a very intense peak.
Yeah.
Whoops!
Go back.
So things that you should do
is to look for what is there
and look for what is not there.
So if you know what's
supposed to be there
in your functional
groups because you know
the structure of your
molecule, then you
can try to identify the
peaks that correspond
to those functional groups.
So if you are anticipating
having an O-H stretch,
like you've made an alcohol
or a carboxylic acid,
then you should see
a giant, broad peak
around 3,500 wave numbers.
And you should also, if you
are making a carboxylic acid,
you should see this
O-H stretch, and you
should see your carbonyl peak.
So you need to be
able to identify
all the peaks that
are associated
with a certain functional group.
So don't say that you have a
carboxylic acid if you cannot
find either--
if you cannot find
both of these peaks.
They will be there.
And then, less helpful
for us maybe now,
but in the ester lab, which
we'll talk about later,
you can also look for
what is not there.
So if you're trying
to figure out
if your synthesis
was successful,
and you start with an
alcohol, and you're supposed
to end with something that
does not have an O-H peak,
then you can look for the
absence of an O-H stretch.
Or if you're trying to
get rid of a carbonyl,
then you can say
what's not there
if you're trying to hydrogenate
some sort of double bond.
You can figure out what is
there and what is not there.
So those are things you can
talk about in your discussion.
And your IR spectrum
in your report
should be attached
as an appendix
with key peaks labeled.
So you can actually,
on your spectrum,
write what each peak represents.
So if you see a
giant peak at 1700,
you can draw an arrow to it and
say, C double bond O stretch.
And the way that
this is typically
reported in the
literature-- and there's
a bunch of different
ways to do it.
You can check out the ACS style
guide for more information.
But you'll say, IR spectroscopy.
You use the type of IR
spectroscopy, which in our case
is going to be ATR.
So there is, like, thin film,
there's potassium bromide
pellets, there's all
kinds of different ways
that you can take
an IR spectrum.
And the method that you use will
also affect the peak intensity.
So that's why it's not as
helpful of a thing to look at.
And then, your units,
wave numbers, and then
your key peaks-- so if you have
a peak that is really broad,
you only have to report.
And you'll see that most of
the peaks in an IR spectrum
are not super sharp.
So this carbonyl peak,
if you look at the base,
it ranges through a good
number of wave numbers.
But when you report it, you
only report the wave numbers
of the highest intensity.
And the instrument will
print that out for you
on your spectrum, so you'll
know what the highest
intensity is for your peak.
So you can report the highest
intensity wave numbers
for each of your peaks.
And if you know what the
peak is, in some cases,
people will put what
bond it represents.
You don't have to.
It was acceptable
to do it both ways
according to the
ACS style guide.
So that's kind of up to you.
A little more helpful for
the person reading it, but--
So if we want to take
a look really quickly
at a couple of IR spectra
of molecules that--
well, this one you may know.
So this is the IR
spectrum of ethanol.
And what is the major feature
that we care about here?
So there's the C--
C-O, but the-- yeah, there's
the O-H. So the biggest,
strongest feature
here is our O-H peak.
And O-H peaks are
typically quite broad.
So they're not as sharp and
defined as the other peaks
in the spectrum.
So that's one of the
characteristic ways you can
know if you have an alcohol.
And then, you can look.
And we have some methyl
C-H's and ethyl C-H's here.
So you have alkane C-H's.
And so those show up a little
bit below 3,000 wave numbers.
Great.
And then, you may
be able to find
the C-O bond that typically
shows up around 1,000,
give or take.
So maybe one of those peaks
is your C-O stretch as well.
So sometimes you can go
into that fingerprint region
if you know that there
is something there
that you are looking for.
So the C-O stretch is one
that you typically can see,
and it's typically
pretty strong.
So in this case, it is there.
But, yeah, and then
another example
is this compound, which
is 3, 7 dimethyl octonal.
And what do we have here that's
really strong and sticking out?
D double bond O, again, right
here around 1700 wave numbers,
that's always a dead
giveaway that there
is some sort of carbonyl peak.
And if you have an
aldehyde peak, then--
I didn't write it
up here-- but you'll
have a characteristic stretch
for this aldehyde hydrogen that
is also up here.
And then you have a couple
of alkene C-H stretches,
and a bunch of
alkane C-H stretches.
So in this case, there
is a lot going on
in our stretching region.
And those are the major
features of that spectrum.
So we'll go over this
a little bit more also,
again, when we talk
about the ester lab.
Because you're going to be
using IR for that lab as well.
We can talk about some of the
different functional groups
that you can see in
that case, because we're
going to be dealing
with, obviously,
esters, and some alcohols,
and some ketones,
and some carboxylic acids.
So that is a brief
overview of IR.
So we have one more
technique left to talk about,
and it is the polarimetry.
And to talk about
that, first, we're
going to do another round of
synthesis with your products
that you've separated in
your initial distillation.
So you have your
limonene fraction,
your carvone fraction,
and we're going
to take the carvone
fraction and synthesize
a semi-carbazone, which will
look something like this.
And you will make this molecule.
It'll still have
your stereocenter.
We're not touching that.
So it'll keep your
RS configuration.
And it'll be a solid, though.
So you're going to
start with an oil.
You will go through
this synthesis.
And then you'll end up with
white needle-like crystals.
So you're going to recrystallize
your product very, very slowly.
And your TAs will show
you how to do that.
There's a good procedure
in your lab manual,
but you're going
to do the reaction,
and then you're going to
let it sit in your lab bench
until the next lab period,
so for a couple of days.
And you want the crystals to
grow really, really slowly.
So you will not see them
when you first make them,
but you'll see them,
hopefully, when
you come to lab the next time.
And the slower the crystals
grow, the more pure they are.
And then, we are going to
need very pure crystals,
because these are what
you're going to analyze
by X-ray crystallography.
And like I said, Peter
Muller will come and give you
more information on that.
So stay tuned.
But what we can do
with these crystals
is use them to do
some polarimetry.
So one of the things that
you'll know about your-- so
I said you're going to
make some white crystals.
So one of the ways that we've
been analyzing our solids
is by melting point.
And you can get two
possible diastereomers out
of this synthesis.
So you can either
have-- since there's not
a lot of rotation around
the C-N double bond,
you either have that extra
nitrogen group pointing up
towards this methyl
group or away from it.
And these two compounds have
different melting points.
So you will characterize
your crystals
by melting point to figure
out which of these isomers
you have, the alpha or the beta.
Most people will make
the beta, because it
has less steric
hindrance, so it's
a little bit easier for that
to happen, just synthetically.
And so that's one
of the first ways
that you will characterize
these compounds.
And the second way
is by polarimetry.
And so if we talk
about polarized light
really fast, so what does it
mean for light to be polarized?
It's all going in
the same direction.
And so all-- so you have a light
source, and it emits light.
And all of the
waves are traveling
in all different directions.
But you can put it through
a polarizing filter,
and then you only filter
out the light that is--
that has, like, the molecules
are all arranged in slits
so that it only selects for
light traveling in one plane.
So you can put that there.
And if you-- if I have two
pieces of polarizing paper,
and I put them on top of each
other in the same orientation,
then the light pretty
much gets through.
These are a little bit
colored, so not all of it.
But then, if I rotate so that
the bottom one is selecting
for light going this way,
and the top one is selecting
for light going the
other direction,
then no light gets
through, because it
can't pass through the filter.
So that's what we're
going to-- this
is the essential principle
behind polarimetry.
So if you remember from either
your organic chemistry lectures
or experience before, different
molecules that are chiral
will rotate plane
polarized light.
And so what that means is
if you put a polarizing
filter on your light,
select for light all going
in one direction,
and then you shine
that light through
a chiral sample,
it'll get rotated to a
certain degree based on
a number of features,
but essentially,
how the light interacts
with your chiral sample.
And so if you have two
polarizing filters,
and you have your
sample in between them,
you can rotate one of
them, and eventually, it'll
match up again, and you'll see
all the light come through.
And so that's how you can tell
how much your compound rotates
the light.
So you put a polarizing
filter on each side,
and then kind of
rotate them until you
get all of your light back.
And then, you can
measure the polarimetry.
So that's kind of the way that
they did it in the old days,
but we have an instrument
that'll do it for you.
So you don't have to
worry about that too much.
I'll turn this back
on really quick.
But the rotation, like I
said, we can measure it.
And it's characteristic
of the molecules.
So the R and the S forms will
rotate in opposite directions.
So in our case,
the R form rotates
light in the negative
direction, or counterclockwise,
and then the S form
will rotate light
in the positive direction.
And the R and the S
are not really related
to the plus and the minus.
So for different compounds,
the R might be the plus isomer
and the S might be the minus.
It's something that
you have to measure.
You can't just know off
the top of your head.
And from this, we can
calculate the specific rotation
of our light, which is how
much the light has rotated.
And it depends on the length of
the sample, the concentration,
and the wavelengths
of light that is used,
and then, again,
the temperature,
because that impacts the
density of your solution
or of your compound.
So the way that you're
going to do this in the lab
is you're going to take a
sample of your crystals,
and then you're going
to weigh them out,
and you're going to
dissolve them in ethanol.
So you're going
to make a solution
that you know the
concentration of so
that we can plug that in
for our concentration.
And you will put
it in these tubes.
And then you will insert the
tube into the polar emitter,
and it will shine
the light through.
And then it will calculate
what the angle is
that the light gets rotated by.
And the polarimeter
actually will
calculate the specific rotation
for you, which is kind of nice.
But you can also calculate it.
It gives you all the information
to calculate it yourself
as well.
So this is notated
very similarly
to our refractive index,
in that it is taken
at 20 degrees for the density.
And we use the same
wavelength of light
from that sodium D-line,
the 586 nanometers,
in order to have a
consistent representation.
So you may see these
constants in the literature.
And if the temperature
is different,
it'll say something
like 23 or 25,
or whatever the temperature
they took it at.
And you can also change this to
whatever nanometer wavelength
of light that you used.
But we're going to be
using these conditions.
And then this is the rotation
of the light in degrees,
the length the travels
in decimeters--
so you're going to
measure the tube that you
use in decimeters-- and then
your concentration in grams
per milliliter.
And you can calculate
the specific rotation
of the molecules.
So hopefully, the people
who had different isomers
will rotate-- the light
will get rotated exactly
in the same number of degrees,
but in opposite directions
if we've done
everything correctly.
So you'll see what you
can get from there.
And I think that
is all for today.
Do you guys have any
questions about anything
that we are about to do
in the essential oil lab?
Autumn?
AUDIENCE: Why is-- in this
case, why is gas [INAUDIBLE]??
SARAH HEWETT: In this case,
to be perfectly honest,
I am not super
familiar with HPLC.
I'm sure you could also use it
to separate these compounds.
GC is-- I mean, part
of it is the techniques
that we have available to us.
So there's that.
But this also gets
separated really nicely
based on boiling point.
So it's kind of fast
and easy for us to do.
But I can also-- yeah, we
can talk about it more.
Yeah, no, it's a good question.